il
je m'appelle hélène foutu je suis la
maman de vincent qui est un jeune
autiste qui va avoir 30 ans et ici j'ai
quelque chose à exprimer pour le
parcours entre ombre et lumière qui a
été sa vie ce que je pourrais dire c'est
que je fais je crois qu'il faut compter
que sur soi-même dans l'appât dead par
rapport à l'entourage ou par rapport à
au milieu professionnel et il faut
croire en son enfant et voir l'avenir
selon selon son idée quand on a un
enfant handicapé un toutes sortes de
handicaps
je pense qu'il faut être un peu
révolutionnaire un peu
créatif et
avoir beaucoup de foi en soi et en son
enfant parce que il faut être à la
recherche de tout ce qui est nouveau de
tout ce qui paraît avec une sorte
d'intuition qui va guider notre parcours
et enfin par rapport à vincent mois on
m'avait dit quand il avait 10 ans de
toute façon votre fils il finira dans un
hôpital psychiatrique et il n'y a pas
d'avenir pour les adultes autistes
enfin moi je n'ai jamais cru jeu et je
me suis toujours battu pour que
justement un avenir
vincent a une vie presque normale bon
avec de l'aide bien sûr pour les gestes
un extérieur
il est accompagné pour faire du sport il
peut faire dans une salle de sport de la
musculation comme un jeune homme de son
âge il a aussi des possibilités de
travailler dans une jardinerie et avec
un agriculteur
biologique donc le travail de la terre
le travail aussi de mettre en rayon dans
un petit commerce
enfin c'est du travail qui lui permet de
s'épanouir ça le valorise et il a aussi
des des méthodes qui lui permettent de
mieux communiquer et ça c'est vraiment
passionnant et je crois que on est tous
fascinés par les capacités que peut
avoir un jeune homme comme vincent quand
on met tout ce qu'ils font tous les
moyens qui existent et ça je me bats
depuis longtemps pour découvrir tous les
moyens qui peuvent l'aider à montrer son
intelligence et ses capacités par
rapport à tous les jeunes handicapés je
crois qu'il faut avoir la foi dès la
petite enfance il faut croire à ce
qu'ils sont
ce à quoi ils sont capables et il faut
aussi mettre tout en oeuvre pour les
aider
maintenant vincent peut vivre presque
normalement nous avons fait des voyages
avec lui il peut aussi surtout prendre
plaisir aux choses c'est l'important
l'important c'est ça c'est que même s'il
a toujours besoin d'elle pour pour pour
travailler ou pour
être accompagnées dans pour l'heure pour
le cinéma ou pour même pour les besoins
quotidiens
il prend plaisir au chant ça fait quoi
24 toi tu n'as pas non plus mon oncle
parce que personne n'a bien sûr 62 16 76
non ce qu'il 76 boul le tube du bien à
moi j'allais aussi le travail avec un
jeune autiste comme vincent demande de
la part de l'éducateur un investissement
à très long terme
effectivement il est difficile de savoir
quand les acquisitions seront vraiment
opérationnel humain au niveau conscient
moi je ne remarque pas de progrès d'une
science à leurs trousses très peu alors
en communication facilitée
c'est beaucoup plus évident des fois il
ya des gens qui entrent un magasin et
d'autres qui sortent donc le contraire
de rentrée c'est sûr gentil et très bien
te dis définitive ça ou c'est ça qui
crée ici
enfin c'est ce qu'elle est qu'est ce que
tu veux dire ça ça c'est quoi
il ya deux mots importants qu'il ya un
an aucun avis ni d ou non d'accord il
est là on est bien d'accord voilà moi je
te prouve quoi je te pose d'une gestion
donc tu réponds à la gestion très bien
le mouton il vit dans un endroit
bergerie dans une bergerie
c'est ça et qui s'occupe du mouton c'est
le berger
les séances de travail dure 40 minutes
environ il est difficile de dépasser
cette durée pour cause de fatigue alors
bon qu'au travail tant bien sûr tout ce
que l'on fait en général en
apprentissage de la lecture c'est à dire
les lettres les syllabes et les sons
sont des unités non significative mais
cependant pertinente de la langue et
celle ci je trouve qu'elles sont
apprises très facilement et même
mémoriser et vincent connaissez lettres
connais même des assemblages de syllabes
enfin bon ça ça va pas trop mal
par contre au niveau des unités
signifiante comme les mots et les
phrases j'ai beaucoup plus de mal mais
sur alors qu'il y prend par contre et
c'est paradoxal plus de plaisir où est
le mot facteurs la vase y cherchant très
bien alors est ce que tu te retrouves la
balloune facteurs n'auront pas alors le
courrier tu le mets avec mon facteur que
fait le facteur cru il donne le courrier
peu fait le canis tu me donnes un la
réponse très bien donc c'est bon
maintenant que fait le boulanger alors
tu regardes bien
bien que fait le docteur pas les deux à
la fois il a k'un ligneux
ou ses écrits il soigne les gens
seulement le mot gens dedans et bien et
il soigne ses écrits ou très bien je
travaille donc les deux aspects de la
langue bien sûr des unités significative
et les autres en espérant que entre l'un
et l'autre on arrive quand même à un
apprentissage de la lecture suffisamment
intéressant pour que vincent prennent
plaisir à la lecture de journaux ou
attirer au moins une autonomie
suffisante pour éprouver un certain
plaisir dans la lecture même si ce même
si tout cela reste très modeste
je pense aussi que au fur et à mesure
que les séances se déroulent vincent
humbert de plus en plus aux activités de
découverte au niveau des magazines et
des journaux lorsqu'on fait la pêche aux
moules et si ceux ci pouvaient se
réinvestir dans sa vie future
eh bien ils éprouveraient alors un
plaisir à dans l'autonomie et c'est ce
qu'on peut lui souhaiter de plus je suis
leur hôtel en barre c'est donc 36 ans je
suis marié je sais non voyantes
et j'habite marseille en fait j'ai fait
au départ une formation de l'historienne
faculté d'aix en provence
et puis j'ai ça plutôt marcher un peu de
travers parce que les la faim qui était
pas très très accessible les documents
arrivait toujours trop tard c'était pas
toujours facile et donc du coup j'ai un
peu abandonné ce projet et je me suis
retrouvé dans les années 80 12 492 93 à
me demander ce que j'allais faire et
j'ai croisé à cette époque là des gens
d'une association qui était à 0
montpellier à l'époque et qui s'occupait
de faire du loisir pour les personnes
handicapées visuelles et j'ai trouvé
qu'ils avaient une certaine dynamique
par rapport au milieu associatif que je
connaissais à l'époque à marseille et je
me suis dit tiens je croyais pas léser
les dossiers des études de la scolarité
j'ai commencé la scolarité à l'institut
régional des jeunes aveugles à marseille
j'avais à peu près cinq ans quand je
suis entré j'en avais
j'étais après le battre quand j'en suis
sortie j'avais beau battre quand j'en
suis sortie en 87
ce qui est intéressant c'est que bon
c'est à l'internât donc j'y ai passé
d'assez bon moment venu mais en même
temps l'ennuie de ce type de l'éducation
spécialisée
c'est que on vous fait tout vous avez
toujours les transcriptions moment vous
avez toujours les le moniteur qui est là
quand il faut le prof qui va
s'intéresser comme comprenait pas tatati
et tatata ça se passe plutôt bien
après quand vous arrivez en intégration
en glisse et ça reste toujours assez
facile parce que vous avez toujours les
transcriptions quand même le soutien
scolaire qui éventuellement vous est
donné aussi par contre quand vous
arrivez à la faculté
là ça change parce que l'intégration
universitaire des personnes handicapées
en 87 s'était pas encore le top
d'ailleurs savez toujours pas mais c'est
une autre histoire
mais c'était pas le top dans la mesure
où les bien sûr on peut toujours compter
sur les professeurs qui sont quand même
assez attentif sauf des cas particuliers
j'ai eu deux cas particulier de
professeurs particulièrement désagréable
l'un qui m'a demandé de lui expliquer
une carte géographique alors que je ne
vois absolument pas que j'avais jamais
eu de carte c'était la carte d un du
xviie siècle
bon enfin c'était en plus à un oral
d'examen donc il m'a mis complètement ma
d'histoire déstabiliser complètement
j'ai raté mon oral et j'ai raté mon
examen aussi et le second cas c'était
professeur j'avais voulu faire du russe
à la faculté et la difficulté c'était
que je n'avais pas trouvé de livres en
braille qui j'avais trouvé le livre
qu'il avait indiqué et j'en avais pas
trouvé d'autres non plus sa très tard
dans l'année et donc je n'ai pas pu les
utiliser évidemment et quand j'ai passé
l'écrivain ça s'est passé pour pas trop
mal mais plutôt mal quand même parce que
j'avais pas trop de vocabulaire c'était
pas évident et quand j'ai passé l'oral
c'était encore pire parce que la
lectrice nous a interrogés on a
interrogé sur le livre dont elle savait
pertinemment que je ne l'avais pas donc
j'ai été complètement déstabilisé
évidemment quand on a 18 20 ans ça
déstabilise bien ce genre de choses et
est bien quand je suis allé trouver le
professeur pour lui dire mais enfin vous
auriez quand même dû nous donner les
deux points qui n'a aucun projet la
moyenne pour que celui ci je puisse
avoir le l'unité quoi il m'a dit oui
mais vous comprenez de points c'est trop
je ne pouvais pas vous les donner quand
j'ai dit quand même quand vous savez la
difficulté que j'avais toute l'année
c'est des cas particuliers à côté ça
vous avez des professeurs qui sont
particulièrement sympathique les soirs
de solide par exemple qu'il a laissé
tout le temps que j'avais roulé à
l'examen puisque les bus les abords le
sujet ça m'avait complètement ses
supporters il m'a dit vous en faites pas
prenez votre temps et pas eu de problème
du tout et alors que vous avez aussi des
élèves qui des étudiants qui sont
particulièrement son talent et qui ont
duré dix états unis
heureusement qu'il ya une solidarité
entre les étudiants
j'ai fait une formation par la suite
mais en 2003 de d'animateurs
socioculturels diplôme d'animateur
technicien mais je me rends compte que
c'est pas du tout évident de faire
d'animation culturelle pour les
personnes non voyantes parce que ici en
tout cas elle se mobilise pas ça fait
très longtemps que je dis que ce qui
manque dans les associations de
personnes handicapées c'est le travail
en direction des valides pour leur faire
comprendre que va être handicapé c'est
pas quelque chose de j'allais dire
d'abominables et 2
d'absolument qui mérite que ça mérite
peut-être la compassion mais en tout cas
ça mérite pas ni le rejet ni la peur ni
tout ce qu'il ya de négatif autour du
handicap c'est un travail que les
associations en tout cas les seules deux
personnes déficientes visuelles ne font
pas le travail de sensibilisation dans
les écoles le travail de sensibilisation
auprès des entreprises
le travail d'information auprès des
valides et même le partenariat avec des
associations de la lide ne se fait pas
ou se fait très très peu et du coup je
me suis dit qu'il y avait une passerelle
à créer entre justement ces associations
de personnes handicapées et le
et le public valide et les associations
des abymes et du coup on a d'abord
commencé en septembre et octobre 2003
par monter une émission de radio qui
fonctionne toujours qui s'appelle
handicap tribune et qui donc avait pour
but d'être un rendez-vous de libre
expression pour les personnes
handicapées d'une part indépendamment de
leur association
mais aussi pour ces associations de
personnes handicapées pour créer une
plate forme d'information à destination
de tous les publics
l'idée aussi c'était de que des
auditeurs valide justement puisse
intervenir soit parce qu'ils étaient de
la famille de personnes handicapées soit
parce que ça les intéressait d'une façon
ou d'une autre il avait envie de
s'informer ou de poser les questions
donc l'idée c'était de rassembler tout
ça est de créer un une plate forme entre
entre les différentes catégories de
publics et donc cette émission
fonctionne toujours
c'est radio galère qui nous a accueillis
en septembre - 2003 et qui continue donc
de nous accueillir tous les mois le
troisième mercredi de chaque mois pour
une heure et demie de démission avec des
thèmes différents selon les émissions et
là nous avons créé en janvier et en
juillet pendant 2004 une association
pour pouvoir
soutenir un petit peu ce projet parce
que jusqu'à présent ils étaient soutenus
par nos propres financements nous faut
un personnel et l'est toujours
d'ailleurs dans la majorité mais on a
quand même maintenant quelques adhérents
pour nous aider à soutenir un petit peu
ce projet et puis l'idée c'était qu'avec
une association on pouvait aussi tenter
des concours pour obtenir quelques fonds
on l'a fait d'ailleurs on a raté des
beaux jours comment ça on attend que nos
prédécesseurs
daschle a terminé plus en va en planches
au travers
d'accord je veux les places et voilà qu
elle l'indiqué la salle indicatif un
vecteur et la doter les interviews
qu'elle aurait la visite d'accord ok ok
ben oui je sais que c'est la peur
pendant ce temps la musique avant
l'interview d'accord mais donc c'est le
deuxième vice comme vous le savez mais
d'abord il a les bras jambes partisante
et quelques infos éventualité qu'il a
fait et bien bonjour chers amis il ne
voit pour un nouveau rendez-vous de
handicap tribune alors donc on va
prendre 20 tout le sujet de notre
dossier
qui donc cette fois ci est consacrée à
la représentation des personnes
handicapées à l'écran donc au cinéma
en fait j'ai voulu faire ce dossier
parce que quand nous avons voulu faire
ce dossier parce que j'avais assisté au
mois de mars dernier à lyon à une
conférence qu'a donnée donc l'auteur
d'un livre qui s'appelle handicapés
cinéma justement celle ce monsieur
s'appelle jean clottes de gérard bonne
forme pardon le livre est paru chez
chronique sociale en 2004 et donc
monsieur bonne foi analyse comme ça au
fil des pages 86 films depuis le début
du cinéma jusqu'à aujourd'hui montre
l'évolution de la représentation des
personnes handicapées dans ses films
alors je l'interview qui va suivre est
en deux parties il y aura une pause
musicale au milieu et donc j'en
ferrat la porte à droite une chanson qui
était paru il ya quelques années déjà
sous froid célèbre maléfiques est 7e
tour sur l'album si vous voulez la
retrouver la jungle et le saut enfin la
nouvelle annoncée concernant les
accueillant gastrique
oui alors en fait il y a eu en début du
mois de juin une personne handicapée
d'orange qui portait plainte contre la
sncf
parce que ce qui s'est passé c'est que
est là on lui à le refuser l'accueil en
gare à ange la prise en charge donc pour
le sens puisqu'elle était en elle est en
fauteuil certaines personnes et donc
auparavant elle avait une prise en
charge de la part d'un agent de l'art
pour descendre du toit ou pour y monter
et pour le virement
aller jusqu'à sortir de la gare alors
que là maintenant et bien la sncf
interdit aux agents de d'un bon nombre
de gares de prendre en charge les
personnes handicapées parce que les
équipements ne sont pas il n'ya pas les
équipements nécessaires pour le faire
alors la direction régionale de la sncf
ici on s'est dit qu'il ya que 2 150
gares en france qui sont dotés de
personnel d'accueil spécifique pour les
personnes handicapées et ben ailleurs
comment on fait ça il faut que le
personnel refuse la prise en charge des
personnes handicapées ou sinon s'ils
peuvent pas refuser au dernier recours
ils ont qu'a confié les personnes
handicapées aux pompiers alors pourquoi
pas deux fois
ça va faire beaucoup d'interventions
pour les banquiers on dirait bonjour je
me présente la belle vie en centre euros
pour résumer un petit peu les activités
donc d'abord gfa ses activités
professionnelles et et scolaire où l
étudiante il donc je
je prépare une thèse de doctorat en
droit à la faculté d'aix en provence et
parallèlement je suis chargé
d'enseignement en droit social donc à la
faculté et j'exerce aussi une activité
de l'assistante justice à la cour
d'appel d'aix-en-provence
la chambre sociale donc ça c'est pour
mes activités je dirais professionnels
donc à côté de cela je me suis engagé au
cdh e où je suis au conseil national
donc en tant que représentant des
affaires juridiques est également nommé
au bureau donc pour les tabliers un
petit peu la politique du collectif
démocrates handicapés
donc pour revenir en fait en quelque
sorte dire à l'insertion des personnes
handicapées dans le milieu du travail de
scolaires
je pense que ce qui est primordial c'est
l'intégration scolaire
je dirais que j'ai eu la chance alain
tanguy mecs que je viens d'un accident
montferrand accident est intervenu en
que j'avais 23 ans et je venais d'avoir
la maîtrise en droit
donc ça m'a permis de continuer mes
études et d'être intégré en fait dans le
milieu universitaire et donc c'est comme
ça que j'ai pu continuer donc à faire un
dea et ma thèse
par la suite commencé ma thèse et de
poursuivre vers l'enseignement
donc je pense que lorsqu'une personne
est atteint d'un handicap
il faut qu'elles puissent intervenir en
fait au système scolaire pour pouvoir
être intégré à la vie sociale
après mandela c'est une professeur de ce
troisième cycle qui m'a proposé de faire
une thèse kamal est et un pack serait le
moyen de me réadapter à la vie
quotidienne en fait ça permettait de
d'aller tous les jours la vague
des recherches de côtoyer du monde donc
j'ai commencé par faire ma thèse donc
dans une première année que je fais que
des recherches et l'année suivante il ya
un professeur pour lesquels avec lequel
j'ai faim qu'il avait enseigné
lors de mon dea qui m'a proposé de pas
que je sois son sont chargés de td donc
pour les enseignements de droit social à
la fac
donc c'est en fait une véritable
insertion dans le monde professionnel
est aussi une reconnaissance de la
personne handicapée au sein du monde
universitaire et je dois dire que j'ai
été très soutenue par le corps
enseignant le doyen de la faculté
le président d'université pour ça qu'il
était quand même quelques soucis au
niveau de l'accessibilité de
l'université en fait tout est mis en
oeuvre pour me faciliter mon activité
d'enseignement donc en ce qui concerne
mon activité
j'irai d'enseignement à la faculté donc
matériellement il ya en fait un mini
plus que kim est réservé en fin de
chaque semaine pour mes horaires de
cours donc il va me chercher chez moi
c'est un truc qu'on appelait ça un petit
taxi bus qui vient d'entreprendre chez
moi et qui me mène jusqu'à la la faculté
et ont la faculté g il ya 10 heures
place jeunes qui sont donc réservées
pour les étudiants handicapés et donc
ces personnes n'ont même jusqu'à matane
le court où là je fais mon cours pendant
une heure et demie ensuite il me
récupère et donc à la faculté de droit
donc d'aix-en-provence
on a une salle qui nous est réservé dans
laquelle on peut travailler ou là des
ordinateurs il ya des logiciels pour
présenter pour les personnes malvoyantes
donc faut tous qu'ils en braille et les
emplois jeunes nous aide un mois
particulièrement et même dans mes
recherches
donc pourquoi pas rêver cours par
exemple mais également mes recherches
pour le pour l'écriture de ma thèse est
aussi toutes les recherches que je peux
avoir à effectuer pour mon travail des
six en justice à la cour d'appel pour la
faculté en fait toutes choses qui ont
une accessibilité
j'ai eu la chance de monter bad ou la
scène étaient accessibles donc je n'ai
pas eu de soucis et la finlande pour une
pour tout ce qui concerne l'enseignement
qu un que j'exerce j'ai toujours eu des
sales qui était intestines et quand on
m'avait
quand elle ne l'était pas il y z'ont ils
sont chargés de salles et m'ont donné
des dessins mieux adapté je dirais il ya
quelques petits soucis c'est les halles
où il ya des colloques des fois que je
supplie par exemple vaut au deuxième
étage de la faculté est donc là qui nous
l'ascenseur n'est pas accessible
essayez donc les appariteurs de la
faculté qui qui me transporte pour que
je me rende sur le lieu du colloque ou
ou le lieu du court mais en fait mon
tout temps que j'arrive à les y ont des
lieux que non je désire j'aime voyager
parce que ça permet de découvrir découle
de cultures différents des gens
différents et au niveau historique
c'est vraiment très intéressant donc
c'est pour ça que j'essaie de faire deux
visites m plusieurs capitales dans les
pays de l'est
alors le plus contraignant dirais pour
les personnes handicapées enfin surtout
à mobilité réduite
d'une part c'est tout les masses et
l'accessibilité d'hôtel donc notamment
avec les les marches il ya très peu de
talent qui sont accessibles à parler les
grands hôtels donc en fait on on
s'adapte on peut donc ça serait un petit
peu le côté nous faisons ce qui concerne
l'hôtel
donc je le précise tout à l'heure moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir des débutants
avec des amis l'ont qui veulent m'aider
mais ce avec une personne seule gérée
par alpha tétraplégique ne peut ne peut
pas voyager toute seule je connais pas
de tels qu'ils soient vraiment adaptées
pour une personne stratégique
ensuite les difficultés bien série les
transports monsieur car enfin c'est pas
et adapté là j'ai vu un rom on sait très
peu adapté qu'il y avait des dernières
manches de londres il ya quelques bus
qui sont adaptés mais pas tous sur la
même ligne donc quand il y en a qui
passent et qui est adapté à une photo
d'une demi heure
quel soutien d'autres en conseil et
transporte aussi long mais il faut quand
des taxis donc c'est beaucoup plus
onéreux et sinon moment comme quand on
est là pour visiter en marche
donc on va limite ça peut aller j'ai un
théâtre à lévis était ce qui est le plus
adapté jeu j'ai souvenir d'aaland à
l'origine que pour une comédie comédie
musicale s'était adapté je vais à
l'opéra avec la notamment pour le
festival d'art lyrique tout est adapté
de plastique sont réservés on s'est
adapté il faut quand même souligner x et
les places sont limitées
les cinémas sur aix en provence jeune a
un seul qui est totalement adapté les
autres on peut pas accéder aux cinq
arrêts son camp il ya des marches
bon j'ai bien que les personnes soient
ses dévoués et nous a pas apporté les
fauteuils quand c'est des pros taysir
est manuel
ça va c'est quelqu'un qui aura fauteuil
électrique
on ne peut pas accéder aux salles je
suis virginien quoi j'ai 48 ans je suis
déficientes auditives de l'oreille
gauche depuis l'enfance plus exactement
depuis la naissance en étant petit je
tombais régulièrement ce qui faisait la
catastrophe mer bon et puis disons que
pour faire court pendant 25 ans j'ai
traversé différents diagnostics au
niveau de l'oreille depuis l'autosport
jaws jusqu'à la tumeur il est vrai que
c'était pas toujours très simple à vivre
mais disons qu'en gros j'ai toujours
gardé le moral
comment je me suis prise pour garder bon
moral et bien à peu près quand j'avais
25 26 ans g j'ai fait des constats et je
me suis rendu compte qu'en public
lorsque je parlais au public et bien
c'était pas très folichon voire même
jusqu'à nous transformer en une
véritable fontaine et bien j'ai pris les
moyens qu'il fallait et j'ai commencé à
faire des cours de théâtre bien
évidemment au début c'était pas très
très simple mais disons lorsqu'il y
avait le phénomène de la patate chaude
il y avait le problème d'une
articulation qui était pas correct je
m'étais place et pas très bien sur la
scène mais disons que petit à petit les
choses se sont se sont améliorées depuis
je me suis bien débrouillé
avec de vrais mandé nette amélioration
et en travaillant d'arrache-pied
j'ai réussi à franchir l'obstacle
l'obstacle de l'oral et de la prise de
parole en public
jusque là tout allait bien c'était
plutôt positives dans l'ensemble mais à
30 ans il y à un événement qui est venu
particulièrement chahutées ma vie un
jour je me rends mon travail je prends
le métro
jusque là tout va bien je sors du métro
je me suis retrouvée transformée en une
petite poupée de chiffon complètement
désarticulé complètement affalé sur le
bitume et c'était pas vraiment 5 gérer
mes mouvements dans l'espace et je
n'avais plus de sécurité aux quinze
jours après ça j'ai consulté les les
eurl qui ont en fait diagnostiquer la
maladie de manière avec notamment la
perte de l'audition de l'oreille droite
ce qui fait qu'en somme
je n'avais pu ni la droite ni la gauche
s'était pas franchement simple néanmoins
je n'ai pas perdu le moral
j'ai des prix mais c'est vrai on a quand
même de se ré mi disons que j'ai tenu
bon en me disant qu'il devait sûrement
bien y avoir une solution quelque part
est la solution
je les trouvais lorsque j'ai rencontré
une personne qui a accompagné des
artistes des comédiens des chanteurs
d'opéra des danseurs des enfants qui
avaient des problèmes de dyslexie
en somme cette personne aider les
enfants les adultes les professionnels
en participant à améliorer leur audition
et leur coûte je fait le distinguo
car le
l'audition est un phénomène passif alors
que l' écoute est un phénomène actifs ce
qui fait que petit à petit j'ai retrouvé
complètement mon oreille droite
et puis au passage j'ai ça m'a permis de
régler certains problèmes notamment la
dyslexie dont j'ai parlé plus haut mais
aussi la production écrite qui s'est
nettement améliorée et ça c'était
drôlement bien parce que ça m'a permis
de reprendre des études
et puis de faire une production écrite
de mémoire ce qui m'était complètement
impossible avant parallèlement j'ai
continué de théâtre mais d'une autre
manière
parce que meilleure écoute meilleure
articulation meilleure évolution dans
l'espace j'ai compté en public ça
suppose une approche différente du
public
il était plus près de moi j'ai travaillé
aussi plus en profondeur le mouvement la
danse bref tout ça m'a amené à
travailler plus en conscience conscience
du mouvement conscience de l'espace
on sens des autres conscience du son ces
améliorations ont participé à élargir
mes compétences dans mon travail et
c'est ainsi que je suis devenue
consultante en conduite du changement et
coach à la fois dans les entreprises
mais aussi auprès des particuliers
j'aimerais bien ajouter quelque chose à
ce partage en fait depuis que j'ai eu la
maladie de manière d'ailleurs dans
laquelle je ne suis plus puisque
j'arrive à écouter ces signaux
avant-coureurs bon mais là n'est pas mon
propos
mon propos est et de dire que depuis mes
30 ans depuis l'âge de mes 30 ans
jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire 48 ans
eh bien j'ai développé une qualité celle
de l' écoute profonde que j'ai
développés ils travaillaient
quotidiennement plusieurs heures par
jour et je sais que c'est jusqu'à la fin
de ma vie que je vais là travailler pour
travailler à cette écoute profonde
j'ai incorpore aussi la méditation la
lecture à voix haute
en prenant en des textes bien écrits
positive constructive et tout ceci
participe en fait à 1 me donner
dimension positive de la vie un mot
communiqué de l'enthousiaste est une
bonne énergie
oui c'est important pour moi de vous
préciser un des aspects basiques
lorsque j'accompagne mes clients c'est
soit en leur faisant naître soit en
réveillant soient sains améliorant leur
créativité et comment tout ça c'est
possible
eh bien je leur communique les clés pour
solliciter leurs propres ressources et
ça c'est la clé de leur bien-être et de
leur réussite
voilà c'est tout je m'appelle à la
commanderie
atteint de myopathie depuis 47 ans
ben moi ma vie c'est c'est plutôt pour
l'instant 8 8 à 10 heures par jour
devant cette machine là dans mon
ordinateur donc bah voila je fais mon
travail de secrétaire régional
donc il fait partie du bureau dans
beaucoup de courir à répondre de deux
demandes personnelles des fois à prendre
en compte de fait 20 ans que je voyage
tous les hivers avantage était mariée je
partais plutôt quatre mois aux six mois
et maintenant où j'ai un petit garçon
vache par km2 mois décembre janvier
tous les deux mois où j'ai pas la garde
et j'ai sa garde
en échange le mois de juillet vous de
quoi ce petit garçon vous l'aviez de
j'ai adopté on adapte et vietnam donc ça
s'est bien passé quoi qu avec l âge
trois jours il y avait trois jours
comment s'appelle-t-il les os et en
vidéo est là devant maintenant qui donc
je le vois
un week-end sur deux tous les mercredis
moitié des petites vacances et donc
thomas je vais voter non en fait je pars
oil in her aussi pour le climat bon moi
je suis très sensible au froid
et puis là de partir de couper un petit
peu l'hiver comme ça et dans huit jours
dans un pays chaud bien sûr et c'est
important mais aussi le fait d'être
confronté à une nouvelle à d'autres
cultures
une ouverture sur le monde les gens sont
assez importantes
de voir que rien n'est pas on n'est pas
tout seul cette terre avec avec tous nos
biens matériels et des gens qui font
heureusement la gueule et alors que la
bpi le dit en voie de développement sous
développés eh ben ils ont beaucoup moins
que nous et ils sont souvent le sourire
et
donc c'est important de se ressourcer
comprend pas le fauteuil électrique là
parce que c'est trop lourd et cetera
quand je prends un fauteuil manuel je
trouve une personne qui m'accompagnent
le marché sait je lui paye le voyage
elle m'aide en échange quoi donc
et puis la jordanie à part acheter le
billet d'avion prendre un petit peu
d'argent et un bon guide de voyage voilà
c'est cette année un voyage organisé
donc après on cherche un endroit pour
dormir en asian en indonésie ou où un
homme savait l'aviez pas cher du tout
quoi par exemple en est de la ville et
le calcul année on a dépensé 1500 francs
par mois par personne pour deux
personnes 3000 francs donc hôtels
restaurants transports retour en quoi de
l'abonné this un peu le même genre de
tarifs au brana de musique a pas là
c'est cette petite île donc mais sinon
oui le train des bus et puis en en plus
d'argent de pays dits en voie de
développement où se développer ben il
faut savoir que les gens ils sont ils
sont d'un naturel plus plus
on arrive bien s'arranger quoi ils
m'aident facilement pour monter dans un
bus en france par c'est impossible
prendre un ticket de bus on me dirait il
faut monter et c'est avec une personne
ça marchera pas quoi mais que la
bassesse naturellement ou de voyageurs
puis a quelquefois des taxis voilà tout
se passe bien
en fait c'est facile de voyager un
défaut en dur était courageux partir des
petits de partir si loin sans avoir une
adresse à point de chute
je dis à moi je dis plutôt il faut écart
pour ajouter restés tout les verrines
sigouin une époque de ma vie je faisais
aussi la musique assistée par ordinateur
fait ça pendant 4 50
donc je travaillais avec un un
ordinateur atari donc un vieux modèle
maintenant est un synthétiseur le
militant brasles et donc avec un
logiciel qui s'appelle cubase jeu avec
la souris un petit peu avec en
enregistrant des morceaux avec les
doigts aussi
ea a composé les morceaux avec plus
l'instrument et c'est donc pendant
quelques temps c'était voilà c'était
plutôt 8 10 heures par jour devant mon
ordinateur mais pour faire la musique
matin j'ai pu le temps avant une période
de ma vie aussi ses échecs
donc j'étais fan à des chèques pareille
bêtise heures par jour vos échecs avec
l'ordinateur avec des copains dans un
club où gens prennent un petit peu les
échecs aux plus jeunes
voilà bah pareil vu le temps on fait
oublier en ce que je pourrais dire c'est
qu'il ya pas une vie de personnes
handicapées on est tous différents et
puis ben chacun sa vie propre
moi je pense que j'ai une vie un petit
peu atypique par rapport à la vie des
gens même est valide joyeuse tous les
hivers comme j'aime me dire bah sinon
ben j'étais mariée comme comme comme
beaucoup de personnes
j'ai divorcé quand beaucoup de personnes
j'ai eu deux amours des maîtresses et je
travaille pas avoir confiance travaille
pas j'ai pas un travail salarié compte
de personne je vis difficilement avec
avec mes allocations
heureusement que j'ai réussi à faire
quelques quelques économies campagne et
de l'artisanat
suite à mes voyages qu'on était marié on
connaît par an mais d'un petit peu
mais bon malgré tout j'ai quand même un
rôle social je pense à travers le
sillage donc je me sens utile quoi bon
bon ben j'ai aussi un autre social
envoie même d'artisanat premier tour des
échanges et contacts avec avec les gens
parce que c'est important pour toi pour
moi donc voilà j'ai eu six projets j'ai
un peu une vie normale à part par ces
épisodes
hivernale où je m'en vais être aux jeux
déshabiller des copains et monfils
version c'est important
oh
m